okay now let's get to the Democratic
brand because that's really what this
book and the movie are about it's called
Hillary's America and by the way the
picture that you have up here she looks
very Emperor Palpatine from Star Wars
with that intentional well he's wears
those outfits that make her look like
Emperor Palpatine my take on her was
that she looks very Aveda ish yeah
there's a picture in the book yeah yeah
there's a picture of Evita and you know
the Evita the Peron Foundation the
Clinton Foundation this sort of notion
of reigning imperial over a country
third-world izing it a little bit you
know here's a good kickoff point for
this whole thing because Reagan once
said I didn't leave the Democratic Party
it left me and the hidden implication of
that is or not-so-hidden the Democrats
have been good guys it's only recently
let's say with the 60s of McGovern that
they went off the tracks
so I'm actually with this book in this
movie Hillary's Mary I'm sort of
breaking with Reagan I'm saying you know
what no there actually is a very sordid
history in the Democratic Party that
goes back a hundred and fifty years
these were never really the good guys
they sounded like the good guys and they
always understood the importance of
justifying very bad things by appealing
to something noble even during slavery
they try to do that but but if you strip
away that kind of veneer you realize
that there's a lot of bad stuff going on
and so that is laid out rather
uncompromising ly in the book in the
movie yeah so I want to I want to get
into some of that you know it's funny
because a lot of people say to me
they'll say I say I'm a liberal and they
say well we see shifting to
libertarianism and I've realized over
the last year so that most of my liberal
positions whether on gay marriage or
marijuana or whatever else I can
rationalize through a libertarian lens
you know I mean it's the same
rationalization which is why classic
liberal and libertarian are kind of the
same but I did see which is what you
just quoted Reagan I've seen the
progressives leave me my views are the
same they're the ones that went that far
with free speech and all this stuff and
it's like I'm trying to pull you guys
back but not much more I could do
yeah the progressives I think you know
when we look back at the 60s in the Free
Speech Movement and
Berkeley Barb and all that kind of stuff
they it turns out that that free speech
slogan was somewhat tactical because
it's one thing to say I believe in free
speech and so you better give me my free
speech and frankly if I were if our
places were exchanged I would give you
your free speech right as opposed to you
give me my free speech because I'm on
the outside but if I want the on the
inside I'd be do exactly what you're
doing it lost you from having a say yeah
and so that's where there's a parting of
the ways and the libertarians come onto
one camp the true liberals the classical
liberals yeah and you may say the
progressives and the leftists mm-hmm
fall into a different camp
so basically when you're talking about
the inside and outside you're saying
because they're using the suppression
Olympics thing right so that if you are
black or Muslim or whatever wherever
they're putting you in all of these
things and as you said before as as
Indian you're sort of off the chart
because your community has done really
well in America but yeah I think you
would also argue that there is system
there are truly systemic reasons
funneled through the Democrats that have
left black America behind yeah and we're
having this big debate about Dallas and
yeah and you know interestingly the
debate is sort of between the the people
who are who say it's the gun or it's the
cops and on the other side the people
who say let's look at the ideology of
the shooter let's look at his motives he
was a radical Muslim and so on now I
step back from this whole debate and I
go look why is this stuff occurring all
over the place and all over the tall the
time and I think the reason is if you if
you apply the liberal principle what is
the root cause of it well the root cause
of it is that we've actually allowed
places to develop in America that are
very uninhabitable you can almost say
that it would cause PTSD to live in
these places I mean just imagine you
walk around Oakland or inner city
Baltimore Detroit Chicago even Dallas
these places are horrible I mean I grew
up alongside very poor I was
middle-class but poor people in India
but those people are not they're poor
but if you gave them opportunity they'd
be fine yeah that's because their
families are intact and they know the
value of hard work
that just aren't jobs and opportunity
for them but they're fully prepared to
take advantage of it on
the other hand we we have created places
in America where there are there's not
only no jobs but there's no education
there's no family structure to incubate
the kind of values that enable you to be
a successful citizen it's very unsafe
and dangerous so how do you grow up
normal in places like that you don't so
this is what I call the urban plantation
and this is going to be one of the
controversial ideas in the book because
in the past some people I make facile
analogies between slavery and what's
going on now I basically make same
analogy but not in the facile way I
actually say that if you look at the
slave plantation ramshackled home and no
family structure because people are
being bought and sold and it's dangerous
and risky and and as their incredible
punishments for falling out of line and
but there is health care because if the
kid gets sick they call the doctor and
there is a lifelong social security
because the slaves are provided for for
life it's not all that different from
their to the urban plantations with the
only difference of the people in the
urban plantations keep voting for it
okay so definitely I can see why some
people would say this is an inflammatory
thing to say because basically you're
you're pretty much saying that the the
Democratic Party has sort of given black
America just enough to control it sort
of right and at the same time that just
enough is exactly what is oppressing it
and then at the same time they vote 90%
for Democrats yes there's all so I get
sort of it I guess using the word
plantation is intentionally inflammatory
on your part but there's I see where I
see what you're doing there right and
the reason the analogy works is that if
you think about slavery now you own the
slave you don't actually have to feed
him at all the slave is sort of like
your car but then you realize wait a
minute if my car is going to work I need
to look after my car I need to actually
at least minimally make my car function
and so what happened with the slaves is
that you had to give the slaves a
minimum subsistence living right now
look I'm not stupid enough to say that
we have plantation owners running around
in quite the same way but here's what
I'm saying that we have spent over in
our 50 years
trillions of dollars on people
if their problem was just poverty we
could easily have gotten them out of
poverty just take this amount of money
and divide it by the number of people
and a very big number appears right so
how is it that after a half century of
trying you still have these places be
pretty much the same as they were 50
years ago that's kind of a very telling
fact right and I guess the the real
inherent problem is that if you give
people a certain something even if your
intentions are good so let's let's
pretend everything you said or not
pretend let's go with saying everything
you said is totally right but let's say
the Democrat where certain Democrats
intentions are good not that they're
trying to do this that still you create
a situation where if you're giving
someone just enough to survive you're
basically creating a situation where for
them to even go out and get better work
or whatever it is they're not
incentivized to do it because they'd
have to work that much harder to just
have enough just have a tiny bit more
than you're giving them so it really
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
absolutely and I don't deny that there
are rank-and-file Democrats whose
intentions are good and there are even
people who voted for these programs as
intentions are good but it should also
be said that you know there is FDR
saying to fellow politicians look if I
devise my Social Security program this
way no politician can ever undo it in
other words if I make the current
generation of workers pay for the
current you know I could have set this
program up a different way you have a
Social Security account that the federal
government maintains but it's your money
and see your contributions go into that
account and they are an interest and
when you retire you draw on your account
it could have been drafted up that way
but they decided let's not do that
because then if later people decide they
don't want it then they'll just stop the
program and there we go so they designed
it so it was hard to stop
yeah Johnson - very cynical remember
Johnson came out of the sort of
Dixiecrat wing of the southern
Democratic Party very rough guy and the
idea that he sort of suddenly just
became a convert to the cause of the
rise it is ridiculous I mean that's just
not a view of human nature that works
right do you think there's a danger when
we look back on some of the history and
when I was reading the book you know
when you take you talk about any of
these people from from 150 years ago to
50 years ago that you lose a little bit
of perspective on what it was like to
live at that time I mean it's in general
like I went to to Thomas Jefferson's
home in Monticello maybe a year or so
ago and I thought they did a really
great job talking about how he had
slaves but also was fighting to free
slaves but I think that we have a we
have a way about us now where we
automatically we look at somebody we've
completely forget the context in with
which they lived and what things were
like at that time and we want to throw
the baby I would rather like schools
that are taking down names of people
that you know were that were important
cultural figures a year ago or something
like that can we forget that history
shapes us I think this is a very
important point both for foreign policy
and for history because when we're
dealing with other countries is is
similar in that in that there's a
culture there and there's a whole
ecosystem there and if you'd have no
idea what it is you're not going to be
able to manage it or deal with it in a
very sensible way yeah the founders you
know the founders get together in
Philadelphia now they represent 13
states slavery is legal in every one of
those thirteen states not just in the
southern ones in all of them yeah now
they're deciding whether to make a union
now the people say well the founder
should have outlawed slavery well the
founders outlawed slavery all the
thirteen guys would have gotten up and
gone home you know or at the very least
you could you you a whole bunch of them
would have you could not have gotten all
those guys to stay in a union that did
that so the point being that we're now
insisting that the founders follow an
option that was not in practice
available to any of them yeah they were
choosing okay either we have slavery
allowed for now and build an
anti-slavery country that will
eventually abolish slavery or we don't
have a country choose those are actual
options we don't have some third option
of having an anti-slavery country and
getting everyone to join right right
sort of taking an imaginary moral
position as if it could be done tomorrow
like that and and it also shows that the
failings of all of us as humans which I
think everyone forgets because when I
was at Monticello they when I took the
tour I thought they did a really nice
job of saying you know he was writing
all of this stuff and made his life
about freeing slaves and giving the
underpinnings of some of this and
same time we know that he was having sex
with that in a couple of his slaves I
think at least and had a child with one
of them I would think by by standard
definitions of 2016 he would probably be
considered a rapist I mean if he you
know because he owned this he owned this
woman and was having sex with her we
don't know if it was voluntary so I
think that's sort of moralizing
different errors is just really
dangerous I think it is for us almost
unimaginable to put us into those
plantations and imagine what life was
like and whether like could for example
Sally Hemings the woman with Jefferson
is it possible that normal human
affections could have cooperated in that
context now like traditional feminist
theory would say never would say you
know just because this man has such
supreme power over her that the idea
that she could in any sense have loved
him but then the same feminists who say
all this and write all these complex
books about it when it comes to Bill
Clinton and there's something there and
well you know you know so so that's the
this is where there's a certain kind of
feminism loses moral credibility yeah
because suddenly it's okay when the
Queen Bill Clinton did it because we
kind of need the Clintons to carry out
our agenda and essentially what Bill is
basically saying is I can do whatever I
want as long as I take the correct
positions on women's rights right and
that's it so that's an interesting segue
to something else that you talked about
in the book that basically you argue
that that Hillary and Bill this was sort
of a marriage made in in in Mordor or
something whereas made in hell related
how I was trying to find a little more
creative because basically she knew that
he sort of had these sexual proclivities
and all this stuff and that she could
sort of use him in a way to ultimately
get what she wants which is the title of
your book that book they're both very
ambitious and I think the difference is
that Bill has the natural talent
politically he's likable he's gregarious
he can talk you out of anything hmm
and he has that kind of sincere look
that he gives even when he's
pathologically lying right now Hillary
cos also a pathological liar but she can
pull it off and so I think Hillary
realized early on that if I'm going to
make my way politically I actually need
this guy
and I need him to be attached to me and
I actually need to figure out a way that
he can never actually get away from me
because he's my pitchman you know he's
gonna sell my product and and she
realized that you know this guy is
basically a sex addict he knows it I
know it and the only question is how can
we how can that now become the basis for
a very peculiar type of marriage and and
I think that the reason it did is
basically Hillary says to Bill okay bill
listen I will become the manager of your
sex addiction I'll make sure it doesn't
kill you politically because the truth
is Bill's in Arkansas I mean even I mean
the mores have liberalized and so on but
this kind of pathological behavior
doesn't fly in Arkansas so so Hillary
had to manage bill from day one and if
you read the Clinton biographies it's
obvious that that builds campaign
managers would give full lists to
Hillary of all the women and so on so
Hillary knew about this from Arkansas
days and yet every time it happened she
had to feign shock and go through this
ritual of I'm not speaking to Bill
here's Chelsea and I walking on one side
of the beach and bill is all by himself
he's in the doghouse and the media plays
along with this big little charade and
the reconciliation you know it's all
comical and it's all pathetic right I
can I can't believe we're considering
the possibility of going through it
again right so basically you're saying
she while she was saying this is a vast
right-wing conspiracy what's basically
engineering the conspiracy totally it
just wasn't a right-wing it wasn't a
right-wing conspiracy at all in fact I
mean what Juanita Broderick Kathleen
will he's on right wing can polish owns
I mean so no these are people who have
just come out one after the other
so I think I think a lot of people think
builds the bad guy and Hillary isn't
like a plantation wife you know has been
suffering while the master has been
making good with all the slaves when the
mulatto is running on the foundation but
I think in this case it's not that
Hillary is not the enduring suffering
life I think with Hillary and Bill it's
sort of wink wink they both know what's
going on and they've they've played a
kind of a diabolical game with this so
how do we as a nation extricate
ourselves from this political mess let's
say everything you've laid out about you
know the history of the Democrats which
now leads us
- Hillary is right let's say I can tell
you're not fully sold on Trump I think
there is that fair to say yeah you get
to say you don't strike me as fully sold
so I so I think most people are not
happy about either one of these I I mean
I even see on Twitter the people that
all day long are telling me how
wonderful Trump is there's an there's
definitely an element of yeah we don't
know what his policies are we just like
that he's wrangling the system and I
understand that and I think all the
Bernie people that are now very
disappointed that he's supporting
Hillary I understand that how do we
extricate ourselves from this crazy
system i Gary Johnson on here who's
running as a libertarian and I got to
sit with him just like this and look him
in the eye and I thought this is a good
man this is a good decent man and I
don't agree with him on everything but
at the very least we need a third party
right at the very very least well we
haven't had a third we haven't been able
to create a three-party system the
Europeans have political structures that
allow for multiple parties right now a
third party would either harm one side
or the other side so right now if you
had a third party a libertarian party it
would hurt Trump uh-oh but that's for
sure because I'm sorted I don't know
which way he pulled from at this point I
think people are so frustrated with both
of them
that I think you I think it would be a
mad no traditional II that's what it
would think he's gonna pull more when
they're more likely to happen is that if
the Republicans take a terrible beating
in November and let's say lose 40 states
which is you know which would be a rout
yeah uh then you're more likely to see
the remaking of the Republican Party the
Republican Party would then undergo this
kind of a severe internal convulsion
probably a lot of its leaders would be
thrown out and the Republican Party
would have to say are we a libertarian
party are we a social conservative party
what are the elements that define us
it's kind of the crisis that the Whig
party went through in the middle of the
19th century and essentially the Whig
party collapsed and you got the
Republican Party but not a three-party
system the Republican Party replaced the
Whig party and became the UH main
opposition party to the Democrats yeah
so but with all that being said I mean
how do we do it how do you actually get
another
partying but I get what you're saying
that maybe we just need to replace one
of these parties but I would argue we
need it seems to me that our political
debate really is about this wide and
we're constantly debating it like this
there's a reason that Wall Street gives
like 51% to the Republicans and 49% to
the Democrats and that switches half the
time that we need something like this
and it's not about just replacing these
parties it's about getting a whole new
set of ideas in there yeah it totally is
you know when oh one thing I miss is
when I was um well when I was in my
teens and early twenties I looked up to
people like Irving Kristol and judge
Bork and Jean Kirkpatrick Solzhenitsyn
Hayek Milton Friedman so these
luminaries now will help to define the
debate then are no longer on the horizon
but what's troubling is I don't see
replacements for them it was also the
case when I was at AEI the American
Enterprise Institute we would have
conferences with the Brookings
Institution which was a counterpart on
the left and there was a lot of common
ground in other words the the Brookings
guys would say you should spend more
money on schools and the Conservatives
would say all right we'd consider doing
that if you'd consider imposing more
rigorous academic standards so you could
have something called additive
compromise which is not that we take you
and me and go in the middle but we do
what you want to do and what I want to
do and we compromise by achieving both
yeah and and so that kind of common
ground has become extremely rare by and
large of Obama does something the
Republican job is to block him um and
and I think part of the reason for that
is the belief that what Obama wants is
actually fundamentally not what we want
America to go it's not the case of two
people who agree on a goal and I only
disagreeing about means it's like one
guy wants to go to Chicago and the other
guy wants to go to Maine right so you
don't want to end up in so why would I
possibly board his bus right so I guess
in that regard you would probably agree
with Marco Rubio in a certain way that
his one mantra kept being about that
Obama fundamentally wants to alter this
country and that's what your previous
movie was I'm pretty sure he got it from
me
I mean I was in my mind trying to take
it from me I mean he kept repeating it
like a robot even though they kept
trying to get him to say something else
and he seemed unable to get off that
switch but
but people didn't really hear that
message no no and I think I think it was
the wrong time and place I mean look
Obama's basically run through his course
this is an argument that's not intuitive
because we always assume that our
presidents we elect them to do the best
for the country we assume that they mean
well and I think Obama means well in the
sense that unlike Hillary Obama's not in
he's not president to make money he's
not trying to enrich himself he has
ideological goals now I think the
ideological goals are bad but they're
still held sincerely and and and and it
takes some argumentation I mean I had to
write I wrote two books on Obama I made
a movie about him just to sell that
argument even to conservatives were a
little bit shaken by at the IDS
anti-colonialist and motivated by the
dreams of his father
so Rubio was sort of like touching on
all that but without even attempting to
clarify or elaborate
you